ja und es gab einen sprengstoff anschlag
auf das büro der linken auf dem
friedensplatz in oberhausen war ein
sprengkörper detoniert gegen 3 uhr 20
kam es dann zu einer heftigen explosion
dabei wurden die schaufenster zerstört
das parteibüro völlig verwüstet die
druckwelle war so stark dass auch
gegenüberliegende geschäfte beschädigt
wurden zum glück wurde aber nach ersten
erkenntnissen niemand verletzt eben nur
diese sachschäden hinweise auf einen
oder mehrere täter gibt es bisher nicht
und zeugen werden gesucht da werden sie
sich bitte sofort an die polizei sollten
sie da etwas verdächtiges gesehen haben